so you've got a pretty stock standard
it's about as stock standard as you can
get set up for frozen oh yeah for this
question in terms of its parabola its
vertex to the origin x squared equals 4a
why everything looks normal
with the exception of one feature this
guy so Q uncharacteristically is not a
point on the parabola usually we would
make it you know an alternative point on
the parabola Q is flirting out here in
the middle and it's divided its it's
made from dividing this interval
internally in this ratio okay so you
guys probably went to the reference
sheet at this point you went to your
internal ratio division formula back
when I taught you that formula I
mentioned that this is not what it looks
like the letters are slightly different
and I believe the numbers are in
different order double check that the
reason why I write this is just because
this is what's burned in my brain and I
think in fact the textbook has something
similar to this whether you use this
form or the form that's on the reference
sheet it doesn't matter which one so
long as you know which form you're using
and you know where to put letters for
instance for me I know that the thing
that's weird about this is that the
ratios the parts of the ratio are in
reverse order up in the numerator okay
that's the only tricky thing you need to
remember about this everything else is
fine okay
so you can see my substitution then once
you've evaluated you get your 280 there
plus 0 80 squared plus 80 squared and
that gives you the 280 squared that you
need so Part one falls out quite nicely
ok
part two I'd like you to help me walk
through what are they asking for the
gradient of gradient Oh Q so o of course
is our origin over here so they're
interested in the gradient of that line
we just went and found out where Q was
so this is just a matter of rise over
run okay but since we know that since
we're comparing to the it's moved of
course since we're comparing to the
origin this is rise and this is run do
you see that so you can write to a T
squared over
one horse a squared divided by two
eighty over one plus t-squared
and you can see you simply end up with T
right everything else cancels which as a
point of curiosity which is never
referred to in the question which I
think is I don't know why they wasted
this result but anyway what we know what
the significance of T is don't we we
introduced the parameter T for a very
specific geometric reason what was it
it's the gradient of the gradient of the
tangent at that point correct which
means that these two lines here are
parallel that's kind of it's kind of
nice which they never use I don't know
why anyway okay so that's curious right
now we come to part three and the rubber
really hits the road what is the
question even mean this is part of why
so few people in the State got this
question using this result or whatever
else you want sure that Q lies on a
fixed circle of radius a show that Q
lies on a circle somewhere here with a
fixed radius a hmm now this is tricky
because we don't we don't we have it
like where's the circle where's the
circle this is actually quite hard to
visualize it you have to do a lot of
thinking to get there what we're gonna
have to do is imagine a fair bit I hope
you have drawn a good diagram because
we're going to draw over the top of it
what I want you to notice is I need to
get a hand tool number one on somewhere
where this circle is going to be okay
and then secondly I've got to think that
well what's the best way to prove that
the circle really is a circle okay so
here is the first very obvious question
I'm gonna ask you I make it nice and
simple to begin with this fictitious
imagined circle is it inside the
parabola or is it outside this is inside
this is an easy question to answer
because by definition you can imagine
moving P about right
wherever P is going to be Q will be it's
an internal division right so it's
somewhere in here okay now where
specifically well
it's not that hard to imagine all my
markers were here if I were to take the
position of pay and reflected across
over that way right that would make it
somewhere over here I'll call that p2
right so now if I position this interval
again I guess Q would also be reflected
horizontally across does that make sense
so I'll call that q2 right
so okay is a spot here a spot here where
else could this go okay now in a moment
I'm going to animate this for you so
that you can see literally where it goes
okay but you need to be able to animate
with your brain okay number one because
you will not have access to the tools
I'm about to show you and number two
because poor souls in decades past had
to animate with their brain through that
any such tools so once you to imagine
put P somewhere else this is a really
easy spot okay
put P like here where do you picture Q
will be going put piece somewhere really
high up here where do you picture Q to
be going how to think about it now I'm
going to show you
okay here's the situation this is where
the diagram started okay now watch what
happens as I move there's P in orange as
I move P around what's going on I'm just
going to pause there for a minute
now I'll actually come back a little bit
hmm
is that what you expected to happen now
this is um this is a little bit weird
admittedly because what defines Q the
green point there what defines Q is this
internal ratio division of 1 to T Square
which is weird like that means the ratio
is constantly changing
because T is changing as I move about in
fact if you're looking closely I'm you
can see the value of T right there okay
so that means that as I move further
down it's not like um it's not like the
Green Dot is always at the midpoint or
it's always like a third the way along
it's going to be like 1 to 2 and then 1
to 3 and then 1 to 4 it changes as T
changes does that make sense okay now
something weird happens when we get to
okay now I'm just gonna pause there I
don't know that was gonna happen just
coincidental hi who are you looking for
yeah
rainy could you guys see me sad about
now please Thanks thank you
just get the door behind you when you go
rainy takes something we had happened
something we had happen I want to go
back to where we originally were in the
original diagram and here is the green
point closer to the focus or is it
closer to P it's clearly closer to the
focus right but at some point that
changes at this point Q is clearly
further from the focus right now it's
closer to here why is that you don't
have to know this time to the question
but I want you to think geometrically
why is that happy Slean okay you've got
one two t squared one is staying put but
T squared is not what is T squared now
it's it's getting small isn't it this is
like close to 1/2 so T squared will be
like 1/4 so now this is like 1/2 1/4 or
that's an orca where to say it I guess
we'd say like 4 to 1 do you agree that
that's why this is happening okay now
think about this
what will the limiting behavior become
as this gets closer and closer to zero
what do you expect to be happening this
is going to become one to some tiny tiny
things it's gonna go towards zero I'm
not saying actually zero because the
ratio one to zero like does that make
sense that means I eat the whole pizza
and you get none of it I don't know what
that is but um what's happening is we
should expect that it's actually going
to land Q is gonna land on P so let's
have a look I'm just gonna let it go to
do its thing that's where it came from
okay so do you remember I said before
you need to animate this with your brain
okay you can picture what's happening
now you can picture what's happening now
you can see the circle cut you can you
see the circle I haven't actually have
stopped some T from going you know
forever but it would go all the way up
up into here right which is actually
very very important for us okay now what
I'm gonna do is let me stop it down here
there we go
this point here when Q goes through the
origin is really really important
because I'm stopping it because it's
obviously your brain is it's very hard
to picture this thing right where's the
circle where's the circle well it's
somewhere like here right something like
that